America grinds to a halt as Americans
lockdown to stop the spread of
coronavirus Joe Biden gets political by
attacking president Trump's response and
politicians spar over the appropriate
response I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn calm slash pen okay
first of all folks we're all gonna get
through this we're gonna get through
this together it's gonna be okay we're
gonna be here with you the entire time
we're adding all sorts of new services
where we can hang out together while
we're at home self quarantine and you're
gonna be spending a lot more time at
home in the next few weeks we're adding
new services here at se Lee Weyer we are
ensuring that you're up-to-date on all
the news here's the truth there is an
expiration date for this thing this is
not going to change American life
forever three years from now we're not
still going to be locked in our homes
but it is a very good thing that
Americans are taking coronavirus
seriously over time it has become
obvious how serious this coronavirus
threat is and it is not a none serious
threat and we're not going to know just
how serious the threat is until a little
bit of time passes so being cautious and
shutting things down
that is the smart thing to do now the
reason that it's the smart thing to do
the reason that we should be shutting
things down and why it's a smart thing
to avoid mass gatherings why it is a
smart thing to use social distancing why
it is a smart thing to stay home a
little bit more than usual and Netflix
and chill the reason for this is because
what we're trying to do is is flatten
the curve right that is the goal you've
heard this phrase before flatten the
curve now here's what people mean when
they talk about flattening the curve so
let's assume for a second that you have
a sort of bell-shaped curve as to when
most of this outbreak is going to take
place and let's assume assume that that
bell-shaped curve is early on meaning
that a lot of people get it very quickly
and let's assume as is the truth that we
have limited resources to deal with the
number of people who are going to be
input in the system well if that if the
number of infections is spread out over
a broader period of time then the
bell-shaped curve is shallower right if
it's spread out over time then you get a
shallower
shaped bell-shaped curve if it is spread
out very quickly then you end up with a
very narrow and tall bell-shaped curve
so I'm going to show you how this works
so let's say that here is worst case
scenario okay this is worst case
scenario if you can't see it I'm holding
up a piece of paper and it shows a tall
or bell-shaped curve
worst case scenario right early on you
get a lot of infections and here is sort
of best-case scenario same number of
infections would spread out over a
broader period of time the reason this
matters is let's assume that the number
of hospital beds available is this
particular line okay this line is the
number of hospital beds available and
it's constant over time that's not real
true there's gonna be an increase in
hospital beds and ICU beds there's gonna
be an increase in the federal
government's capacity to respond and in
private industries capacity to respond
by the way it is imperative to note for
all the talk of Medicare for all in the
federal government handling all the
stuff it is mainly private labs it is
mainly hospitals that have private
funding that are going to be taken care
of a lot of these problems and that's a
very good thing hey America does have
good public health response America does
have some elasticity in its market and
some flexibility in what private
industry is allowed to do the testing
kits that everybody is complaining about
most of those are not gonna be coming
courtesy of the federal government most
of those are gonna be coming courtesy of
private labs that are being repurposed
like quest Diagnostics they're gonna be
repurposed in order to do lots of
coronavirus tests okay so back to this
little chart so let's say that this is
best-case scenario perfect okay so this
is a better graphic as you can see I'm
basically drawing the same thing number
of cases is on your vertical axis time
since first case is on your horizontal
axis Y axis is number of cases x axis is
the time since the first case and let's
say the healthcare system capacity is
the dotted line that you see across the
middle of the screen okay if if there
are no protective measures and everybody
gets this thing early right we're all
out in big crowds ones n-c-double-a
basketball games this thing is spreading
quickly then what you see is all of the
cases grouped very early on right time
since first case everybody's getting
grouped very early okay and over time if
you get put protective measures in place
people are getting it people are still
getting it right you're still getting it
but instead of you getting it in April
you're getting it in September what's
important about that is that if you are
acting below that dotted line then yes
there will be a bed for you at the
hospital even if you need a ventilator
even if you need a respirator that stuff
is available to you if however there is
a glut in the system is what's happening
in Italy this is why Italy is a disaster
area if there's a glut in the system and
there just aren't enough beds you end up
in worst case scenario and worst case
scenario is a wat a lot of people who
are diagnosed and they are above the
healthcare system capacity and that's
when you have to start doing as Ezekiel
Emanuel the founder of Obamacare and now
Obama and Obama Biden advisor that's
where you get health care rationing
right that is worst case scenario that
is the government that is the the
hospital's deciding who deserves care
and who does not and how you prioritize
those people is equal Emmanuel at a very
scary column in today's New York Times
talking specifically about the necessity
before rationing if it comes to that and
how exactly we think about those things
and that of course it's stuff that
nobody wants to think about right this
stuff about are you prioritizing medical
medical personnel right a doctor gets it
does that person get higher priority
than a publicist you're prioritizing
based on age based on health and life
expectancy do you prioritize the 30 year
old over the 80 year old do you
prioritize based on the amount of health
care needed right because if you have
one person who's gonna suck up a lot of
resources and live versus five people
who are going to suck up fewer resources
and live do you pick the five over the
one right you get into basic lifeboat
effects and that's where you don't want
to be so it is very good that is a
country and let's just be real about
this this is not because of the federal
government it's not it's because people
across the country suddenly started
taking varies and private industry
started taking very seriously the threat
of coronavirus hey Disneyland shut down
hey you've seen the NWA n-c-double-a
shot down the NBA shut down I know in my
own community our schools our kids
schools shut down starting on Monday all
right all the schools are gonna be shut
down the the synagogue's are shut down
are shutting down all across I mean to
understand how how crazy this is I mean
I've never seen anything like in my
lifetime you've never seen anything like
in your lifetime unless you remember
1918 in order for you to understand how
crazy this is understand that in Judaism
it is a religious obligation like it is
a it is a full-on Mitzvah for you to go
to synagogue and pray on Saturday with a
minion in Israel for for a couple of
weeks now they've already had measures
in place that say don't go to synagogue
right stay home we'll figure out a
different way for you to fulfill the
obligation if you can't fulfill the
obligation there is too much of a threat
for you to go to synagogue local
synagogues in my area in Los Angeles are
shutting their doors and saying okay we
are not even going to hold services can
we know that in Italy they've shut down
mass which of course is the same thing
they're shutting down religious services
the Mormon Church right the Church of
Latter day Saints they shut down all of
their communal services this is all good
okay this is all smart is what the
American people should be doing and
maybe we'll look at--look best-case
scenario we look back on all of this and
we say well you don't need it too much
right we didn't actually need to do all
that that is best-case scenario but if
we actually want to get this thing under
control if we want to bend that curve
below the healthcare capacity it is
imperative that people exercise
discretion it is imperative that people
continue to do things like washing their
hands
it is imperative they avoid large public
gatherings if you are going to be out in
public you got to have a certain amount
of distance from other people okay
there's all changing our way of life in
it and it cuts directly against it
really does it cuts directly against
what we as human beings tend to do in
times of crisis right when you're in a
crisis when there's a real danger human
beings tend to flock to the herd right I
mean it that's just natural human thing
you want human company you want to be
around other people you want to feel
sick because you feel safer in the herd
right we are a social creature humans
are social animals and now we're being
told okay time of danger isolate okay
that is directly contrary to everything
that we are used to that's right you
know frankly thank God for the Internet
thank God for the fact that we can
communicate as easily as we can in the
modern world that we can FaceTime with
friends and family it's not a substitute
obviously for being in the same room
with somebody or hugging a friend or
shaking hands with somebody right those
that those going away the dodo bird it's
actually quite tragic because these are
ways that we communicate with each other
natural human ways that we communicate
with each other
with that said we are going we here
daily where we're gonna make a point to
try and reach out to you more we're
gonna try and make it a point so that
you don't feel alone we don't feel alone
we're all in this together we really are
and again there is an end point here
even people who are really pessimistic
about this kind of stuff like Scott got
leave before more FDA Commissioner even
he is saying we're not looking at a
forever change here we are looking at a
couple months change and then there
gonna be some permanent changes to our
way of life like you know things may
change as far as how movie theaters are
seated and things may change as far as
how you go to a ballgame but the fact is
that this is a temporary thing a vaccine
will be developed we will get through
this we are gonna bring all resources to
bear and if we're smart about it then we
will have bent the curve so that fewer
people die particularly older and sicker
people and people with pre-existing
conditions because those are the people
who are uniquely vulnerable coming to
gets you more of this in a second
because information first in politics
second okay I'm really tired frankly I
do a political show I'm sick and tired
of everything being political this is
not a time for politics if you are
sitting around and your first thought is
how does this affect Trump this immunes
gonna get reelected or not reelected if
you're sitting there on the left and
you're cheering because you think okay
well this means that Biden's gonna be
President or if you're on the right
going fulminating because focus on the
focus on the virus is is hurting
President Trump you're doing being human
wrong okay that is a secondary priority
at this point the only thing that
matters is saving lives and frankly I
think that I hope that even our
politicians know
I have my doubts as we'll get to in a
second but I think that most human
beings deep down know that this is a
time when we need to put the politics
aside and really focus on what exactly
seem to save lives we can we can get
into more of that in just one second
first let's talk about your sleeve
quality so it's always keeping you awake
at night it may be well thank God for
the internet because the fact is that
thanks to the Internet and thanks to
delivery services you will be able to
get all the things that you could
possibly want in your home anyway we
still live in a land of plenty in a time
of Plenty and that means that if you are
lacking sleep you need the best
available mattress one that is made just
for you
I mean it's particularly true for me
I've got a baby not sleeping a lot when
I am sleeping very important I sleep on
a comfortable mattress this is why I'm
so happy my wife and I did the helix
sleep sleep quiz helix sleep has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper a hot
sleeper whether you like a plush or firm
bed with helix there's no more confusion
no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by GQ and
Wired magazine CNN called it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on just go to helix sleep calm /ban take
their 2 minutes late because they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life they have a 10 year warranty you
get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but indeed you
will helix is offering up to 200 bucks
off all mattress orders just for our
listeners get up to 200 bucks off at
helix sleep comm slash men that is helix
sleep comm slash men go check them out
right now helix sleep comm slash been
hearing me home anyway he may as well
get a really good night's rest on a
helix sleep mattress that is made
perfectly just for you ok so how bad is
this thing going to get well nobody
knows is the answer because we don't
actually know the transmission right we
know it's easier to transmit than the
flu apparently we also know it's more
deadly than the flu according to dr.
Anthony Fauci of the National Institute
for allergies and infectious disease
according to pouchy this thing is at
least 10 times as deadly as the flu we
don't actually know the rates because in
some areas it's a lot lower than in
other areas we don't know because we
don't know if the public health response
is gonna be we don't know how much of
this is due to lack of proper medical
staffing and how much of this is due to
the actual deadliness of the disease
itself with that said it is obviously
very risky and there have been a wide
variety of sort of articles put out
there about how bad this thing could get
in the New York Times has put together a
model nicholas kristof and stuart
Thompson writing what's at stake in
these corona virus pandemic how many
Americans could become infected how many
might actually die the answers depend on
the actions we take and crucially on
when we take them we're working with
infectious disease epidemiologist we
developed an interactive tool that lets
you see what may lie ahead in the United
States how much of a difference it could
make if officials act quickly the
figures are for America the lessons are
broadly applicable to any country okay
so they have a bunch of different
scenarios here as far as what exactly
could happen so they say if we stayed on
current track then the model predicts
that roughly a third of Americans more
than 100 million people could become
infected including more than 9 million
people at one time
right as we take no protective measures
basically that's if we just kind of
leave everything as it is we don't build
up capacity we don't stay home
we don't cancel events that of course is
not what's happening right we're already
moving moving along the South Korean
tack which is lock it down lock
everything down stay home which is the
smart thing to do in this particular
scenario up to a million people could
die in the United States which of course
would be just an unbelievable trauma an
unbelievable trauma to the United States
that'd be if no action was taken and if
the peak of the infections happened in
mid-july that also assumes that
presumably the summer would not really
curtail the spread of the virus which is
sort of doubtful okay interventions
early on mattered an awful lot if there
are additional interventions like ending
public gatherings closing work places in
schools mass testing fortifying
hospitals if those additional
interventions were to begin sometime in
May which I mean frankly I think that it
seems like we've snapped into place
pretty quickly here I mean it's really
early March if that happens then you
could see four point five million
infections the peak and four hundred
seventy five thousand total deaths now
to put that in perspective that would be
like ten times the number of people who
die from the flu every year so that
would still be a massive trauma if it's
even earlier then obviously the numbers
go down if the interventions be in one
month later like in the middle of July
the number of infections climbs by more
than two million you get 2/3 of a
million deaths so moving as quickly as
humanly possible would be the the best
possible scenario they're sort of
suggesting that the best possible
scenario let's say that we put into
action these interventions like right
now according to The Times model you'd
get three million infections at the peak
and you get about three
20,000 total deaths it's like the
best-case scenario okay so maybe they're
wrong maybe that thing wanes in the
summer but aggressiveness matters right
if you if you aggressively act if you if
you get very aggressive like everything
shuts down then this stuff starts to
look more like a seasonal flu if you if
you act right now what's the best-case
best-case scenario you act right now
everything shuts down the schools shut
we stop going to ball games we stop
going to - if we go to restaurants we
stay far away from one another we clean
our areas if you go to the gym you wipe
down all your equipment you start doing
a lot more things at home basically you
revert to sort of a cabin mentality
you're in here with your family you go
on hikes right like that that's sort of
what your life becomes a lot of home
schooling less cut and less communal
gathering if you do that then according
to this New York Times model you got
five hundred and thirteen thousand
infections at peak and 51,000 total
deaths and then it starts to look much
more like a seasonal flu as the New York
Times points out what matters is not
only the total number of infections but
also how many occur at once overloaded
overloaded hospitals and shortages of
ventilators in icy use would result in
people dying unnecessarily from
coronavirus as well as from heart
attacks and other ailments successful
interventions are crucial they flatten
the curve were much better off if the
100 million infections occur over 18
months rather than over 18 weeks right
if you look at the same number of ICU
cases as before but modeled at a much
slower rate to finish beneath the 95,000
available ICU beds in the country then
the number of deaths is a lot a lot
lower so it is really important that
people take aggressive actions right now
not to get in group scenarios this is
according to the scientists okay so I'm
just citing the scientists here it's not
alarmism this is not politically
oriented anyway be smart don't go to big
parties postpone your parties okay if
you're gonna have a wedding you might
think about postponing the wedding until
post July right see where things are at
in a couple of months if you're talking
about major gatherings you might talk
about postponing those major gatherings
if you're talking on a birthday party
you might think about saying okay you
know what next year we're gonna go twice
as big on the birthday party as opposed
to getting together this year listen all
of this hurts I know I know I have young
kids right I have I have a kid who has
six I have a kid who has three I have a
kid who is a week old right I get all
this I've parents who are in their
sixties all right so
I they run the gamut in terms of
vulnerability I understand my kids want
to play with the other kids my kids want
to go to school they don't want to stay
home right I get all of this I want to
eat at restaurants I want to go to ball
games I bought tickets for a ball game
with my dad like a month ago now I'm
very glad that the MLB is pushing back
at season I'm very glad that the NBA is
doing what it's doing lock it down lock
it down be responsible and by the way a
lot of these supply lines are gonna come
back online in terms of hand sanitizer I
don't worry about there being a
permanent outage of hands hands how
there's a rush right now in two weeks
the rush will basically be over there
will be supply lines for groceries
people are not gonna starve in the
United States even in Italy the grocery
stores and pharmacies are still
operating so right now people are sort
of buying up understandably right well
we're all freaking out a little bit so
everybody's going to the grocery stores
and they're buying out the shelves
producer Pavel was was showing me a
picture from his local grocery store and
everything was taken off the shelves
except for the cauliflower oddly enough
turns out that people would rather die
than buy the cauliflower which perfectly
understandable vegan dishes are still
not seeing an uptick in their spike here
but with that said the this will
alleviate the one area of American life
Warbler things will continue to be
produced is in the grocery and pharmacy
section so I wouldn't worry too much
about that the government is gonna take
some aggressive actions in terms of
shoring up the financial infrastructure
we're gonna get some more of this in
just one second first let us talk about
you taking care of a medical problem
that could really affect you anytime but
certainly affects me now if you have
erectile dysfunction you need to make
sure that you get the medication that
you need here's the beautiful thing you
no longer have to go to the doctor in
order to do this most people have to
wait nearly a month to see a doctor in
major US cities and right now given the
strains on the healthcare system this
obviously isn't top priority for a lot
of the medical system but if you got a
needy problem it's a top priority for
you and this is why our friends at Roman
have spent years building a digital
platform that can connect you with a
doctor licensed in your state on your
schedule just grab your phone or
computer complete a free online visit
you'll hear back from a US licensed
physician within 24 hours if the doctor
decides the treatment is right for you
Romans pharmacy can ship your medication
to you with free two-day shipping you
also get free unlimited follow-ups with
your doctor anytime you have questions
or you want to adjust your treatment
plan with Roman there are no commitments
you can cancel anytime so if you're
struggling with edie or hair loss or
cold sores or other issues head on over
to get Roman comms life Ben for a free
online visit and for
shipping that is get Roman comm /
Bennigan's GE T ro ma n comm / Ben for a
free online visit and free two-day
shipping get that medical problem solved
to quickly easily do it do it discreetly
/ get Roman comm so I spent get that
free online visit and free two-day
shipping okay so what exactly are the
measures that have been taken in
different countries around the world
now the measures vary widely if you look
at the the outbreak levels and the death
levels in various countries the New York
Times there their Maps on this are
actually quite good the New York Times
has some some outbreak maps showing
exactly how many people have been
diagnosed in particular areas of the
world the United States currently has
over 1600 diagnoses but we have a
tremendous lack of testing Mike DeWine
the Governor of Ohio basically announced
that maybe there's 1% infection rate in
the state of Ohio already which would
mean presumably a hundred thousand
infections China which has been lying
about his numbers for a long time they
said there are eighty-one thousand cases
in China South Korea says seventy eight
hundred Japan has 1,300 most of those
are from the Diamond Princess cruise
around has over ten thousand Italy has
over fifteen thousand Spain has 3800
France has 2800 Germany has three
thousand these numbers are not that big
on a broad scale what people are afraid
of of course is the exponential growth
as I mentioned yesterday human beings do
not have a great capacity to understand
exponential growth we understand
arithmetic growth right yesterday there
was one tomorrow there will be two the
day after there'll be three and we
understand arithmetic growth the
straight-line growth what we don't
understand is the curve right we don't
own it because the curve looks like 1 2
4 8 16 32 64 and suddenly every doubling
becomes enormous right suddenly you're
talking about doubling from 10,000 cases
to 20,000 cases in the same period of
time it took to double from 1 to 2 ok so
right now what we're looking at in Italy
is 15,000 cases and a thousand death
it's a very high death rate again that
is because of strains on the healthcare
system over there but if you look in
places like South Korea those rates are
significantly significantly lower okay
so what exactly is is happening in in
these various countries that have done a
successful job trying to shut this thing
down according to the New York Times the
the various scenarios that have been
used make a big difference in Benjamin
cowling and way when Lim cowlings an
epidemiologist limb is graduate student
epidemiology they're right about
Singapore Taiwan and Hong Kong talking
about how they Brockie
under control they say in late January
after a sluggish and problematic initial
response the government of mainland
China put in place unprecedented
containment and social distancing
measures in lockdown major cities
noticeably Wu hen the epicenter of the
outbreak and imposed various travel
restrictions throughout the country
there's a piece in The New York Times
that ridiculously suggests that China
bought us time China is the reason this
is a problem in the first place it's
because a poor decrepit country that
runs top-down in a fashion where they
silenced people who are trying to bring
information to the general public
imprisons them shuts them down and then
the country is so poor overall that
people are literally eating pangolins
because they have nothing else to eat
with these crap exotic meat markets you
got a communist dictatorship that is
unable to even shut down the meat
markets that have been responsible for
SARS mirrors and now this one I mean
seriously I I don't want to hear China
getting credit for its literacy programs
from burning okay this is this is not
the China is at fault for this China in
in the international trade sphere is
gonna be held responsible for this
people are not going to create factories
in China at the rate they once did
there will be a diversification
economically away from China in response
to the fact that China has now been the
source of several of these pandemics its
what a disaster area but Chinese
response was a complete lockdown the
testing capacity of laboratories was
rapidly expanded to relieve pressure on
hospitals patients with milder symptoms
were placed in temporary isolation
facilities set up in gyms and event
halls new hospitals were constructed
people who had come into contact with
anyone infected were sent to designated
facilities typically converted hotels or
hostels for prophylactic quarantine home
quarantine was advised only for those at
slight risk of infection
initially all residents of Wuhan
basically were required to stay home
schools and workplaces were closed why
left to dwell after the end of the Lunar
New Year Festival the scale was
extraordinary but it seems to have
worked to contain the spread of Co bed
19 in China the number of new cases
reported every day is a lot lower than
it was before but instead of looking at
China which is obviously a repressive
authoritarian country we should instead
look at some less authoritarian and
impressive countries places like
Singapore Taiwan and Hong Kong we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk now I mean you don't really want to
be in public places so do you really
want to take all your packages slep them
into the post office and then stand in
line at the post office with a bunch of
other people I know might be coughing
instead why don't you just stay at home
and do all of this from home with
stamps.com
stamps.com is completely online plus you
save five cents off every first class
stamp and up to 40% off shipping rights
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just hand it to your mail carrier
or drop it in a mailbox it is indeed
that simple think about how much time
and money you could have saved on
letters and packages over the years with
stamps com you get discounted postage
rates you can't even get at the post
office and there's no equipment to lease
and no long term commitments
stamps.com it's a no-brainer it saves
you time it saves you money it's no
wonder over 700,000 small businesses are
already using stamps.com
you ought to take advantage of any
service that saves you time money and
services that allow you to do both of
those things while staying home and not
being in trying public places sounds
great
this is why you ought to be using stamps
come right now my listeners get a
special offer it includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale with no long term commitment just
go to stamps com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage type in
Shapiro again that stamps comm click on
the mic at the top of the homepage and
type in promo code Shapiro go check them
out right now okay so let's look at some
of these other examples of countries
that have done a good job of locking
down as of midday on Friday according to
these columnist one an epidemiologist
for the New York Times Singapore had 187
confirmed cases and no deaths for a
population of about 5.7 million Taiwan
had 50 confirmed cases including one
death for a population of 24 million
hong kong and 131 confirmed cases
including four deaths for a total
population of about 7.5 million all
three governments have implemented some
combination of measures to first reduce
the arrival of new cases into the
community those would be travel
restrictions as we'll see in a little
while the media intent on hitting
president Trump are ripping on his
travel ban from Europe the fact is dr.
Anthony Fauci who I trust a hell of a
lot more than any of the people
criticizing pouchy on virtually all of
this stuff he was defending the European
travel ban in fact here is doctor foul
Qi specifically talking about why the
European travel ban is a pretty good
idea I think that was a prudent choice
we spent a lot of time thinking about it
discussing it about whether we should do
it and it was the right public health
call and here's the numerical reason why
new cases throughout the world
the majority of them are from Europe
Europe to other countries if you look in
the United
dates and states that have new cases the
majority of them are coming from that
region it was based on that that the
travel restriction was suggested and
accepted okay this is back by dr. Robert
Redfield who happens to be the head of
the CDC he was testifying yesterday and
he suggested yeah of course we
recommended the travel ban like it's not
just that Trump came up with this thing
off the top of his head like there's
some pretty good evidence for it real
risk in in in general right now and this
is why the president took the action he
did last night within the world now over
70% of the new cases are linked to
Europe and in the United States I think
it was now 35 30 states in our country
30 of our 30 states or more were linked
actually the cases of Europe Europe is
the new China and that's why the
president made those state statements
okay so the media obviously are ripping
on Trump for the European travel ban but
everybody acknowledges that a travel ban
shutting down travel for the moment
international at the very least is
probably a good idea these elements
including epidemiologist for the New
York Times continue the other measures
taken by Taiwan Hong Kong Singapore
specifically prevent possible
transmission between known cases and the
local population which has quarantines
and finally generally suppress silent
transmission in the community by
reducing contact between individuals
self-isolation social distancing
heightened hygiene each of these
countries has a different approach
Singapore could take aggressive measures
to block the arrival of infection from
China and they did these Singapore
authorities also undertook especially
intensive efforts to trace the context
of people known to be infected we
already have community infection in the
United States so sort of past that at
this point but
Singapore has implemented all sorts of
recommended personal hygiene habits
using a tissue when you cough or you
sneeze using designated serving spoons
during group meals using trays when you
eat or drink to limit contamination in
case of spills keeping public toilets
clean and dry regular hand-washing
Taiwan took a slightly different tack as
soon as early January
Taiwanese medical authorities would
board incoming flights from Ohana and
inspect and screen travelers on the
plane Taiwan has also taken a rather
mixed approach in its efforts to reduce
transmission within the community home
quarantine has been the predominant
method of isolation even when state
facilities were in fact available and
they've been ensuring strict penalties
against anyone who breaks in isolation
or including fines of up to $30,000 if
you're ordered to stay home and then you
do not also religious institution
suspended services organizers of mass
events were encouraged to defer or
cancel those events Hong Kong had a
different approach their approach again
involved screening people who are coming
in from China and they also recommended
that anybody who arrived from elsewhere
was forced to undergo mandatory 14 day
period of quarantine so all of these
measures are things that most these
measures are things that we in the
United States can do now the big
question is how widespread this is in
the United States right now and the big
shortfall of the federal government thus
far has been the lack of testing kits
available those testing kits are mainly
going to be produced as I've said before
by private industry so well a lot of
people are talking about the evils of
private industry medicare for all in all
the rest of this the fact is that it is
private industry that's gonna be picking
up the slack here it is private
companies private testing companies that
have picked up the slack in fact there
there's new tests that are being brought
out as in like right now that are going
to allow 24-hour turnaround the FDA is
allowing the emergency use of a novel
coronavirus testing system designed by
Roche molecular systems according to CNN
within 24 hours of receiving the
application the first commercially
distributed diagnostic tests receive an
emergency use authorization during week
of a 19 outbreak demonstrating once
again then when you cut through the
bureaucratic red tape it is usually a
good idea can remember just a couple of
days ago the New York Times is reporting
that people were ready to do these tests
in January in Seattle and the CDC and
FTC the fda shut them down because of
the bureaucratic idiocy of all this now
dr. Anthony foul she again being taken
out of context he pointed out that the
ly the testing regimen put out there has
been failing because we just don't have
enough test kits people short-handed
this to say that the government response
is failing that is not what he said
listen to the full clip of dr. pouchy
system does not is not really geared to
what we need right now what you are
asking for that is a failing and yeah it
is a failing let's admit it the fact is
the way the system was set up is that
the public health component that doctor
that that dr. Redfield was talking about
was the system where you put it out
there in the public and a physician asks
for it and you
the idea of anybody getting it easily
the way people in other country are
doing it we're not set up for that do I
think we should be yes but we're not
okay he didn't say the entire system is
failing he said this is a failing it is
up failing the media covered this is the
foul she said the entire system was
failing and the media spun this out of
control to suggest that this of course
is president Trump's fault and this is
where the politics of this thing comes
in we all know what we have to do okay
this is no longer a giant mystery we
know what we have to do we know we gotta
watch our hands we know we gotta we got
to stay home as much as possible we know
we got to avoid populated areas we know
that if we're gonna order from a
restaurant order delivery or order out
we like we know what to do
right this is no longer a broad-based
mystery this is no longer a question of
what to do the only question is what
measures Congress can take to shore up
the economy in the short term which
presumably would include a payroll tax
holiday it might include American
Enterprise Institute has recommended
cash payments to people who literally
cannot make their bills at least in the
temporary in temporary and short term it
would include maybe the government
allowing paid sick leave but the
government the government allowing it
and it being sunsetted so that it's not
a permanent program like Nancy Pelosi
literally wanted to implement in her in
these bills she wanted a permanent paid
sick leave that would include paid sick
leave for like spousal abuse or
something right which has nothing to do
whatsoever with coronavirus like at this
point put the partisan bull crap aside
guys seriously we don't need the
partisan bullcrap
what we need is specifically directed
responses to specific people who are
going to be harmed by this and we need
to make sure that our credit systems
don't fail the federal government is
standing in the breach when it comes to
that sort of stuff and again for all of
those who are saying well aren't you a
libertarian guess I'm a libertarian and
libertarians understand externalities
when the entire system is at risk in
time of war there are no libertarians
when it comes to should there be an army
or not libertarians are not anti a
military when you are under attack and
when a major virus is threatening
externalities I don't know a single
libertarian who is suggesting that the
government has no role to play in the in
the presence of a pandemic
and we'll get to more of this in just
one second and we will get to the
inevitable politicization of a of a time
when things really should not be
politicized I'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about again
another reason not to go over to the
groceries
or of our mercy why would you go over
there just pick up some brush heads
instead why do you not clean your teeth
with the best available toothbrushes the
greatest toothbrush and will be
delivered directly to you I'm talking
about quip toothbrushes quip makes
brushing your teeth twice a day for two
minutes and flossing simple and starts
with an electric toothbrush refillable
floss and anti cavity toothpaste the
product is just fantastic I've been
using it for literally years quips
electric brush has sensitive sonic
vibrations with a built-in timer and
30-second pulses to guide a full and
even clean they'll actually tell you
every time it pulses it tells you it's
time to switch sides of your mouth the
quip floss dispenser comes with
pre-marked string to help you use just
enough so you're not ripping off like
three yards of floss and then wrapping
at eighty-three times around your
fingers and then trying to floss quip
delivers fresh brush heads floss
toothpaste refills to your door every
three months with free shipping so your
routine is always right you don't really
want to have bad luck and hidden frankly
don't want to have unhealthy teeth join
over 3 million healthy males get quip
today starting at twenty-five bucks if
you go to get quip comm slash Shapiro
right now you get your first refill for
free
that's your first refill free I'd get
quip comm slash Shapiro spelled to GE t
qu I p.com slash apparel get quip
dot-com slash apparel quit the good
habits company go check them out right
now okay we'll get to more of this and
the inevitable politicization it was
going to happen and indeed it did
because people just cannot stop they
never stop never stopping is the rule in
American politics and my god folks like
cut it out just quit it we'll get to
that in one second first it is that
glorious time of the week when I give a
shout out to a daily wire subscriber
today it's Casey Ann on Instagram was a
husband who knows the way to a wife's
heart in the pic Casey an is in her car
happily brandishing the greatest most
ugly beverage vessel the world has ever
seen also we have another we have
another picture we have two pictures
today okay that one says best mail day
ever
I got my leftist ears hot or cold tumblr
after two years of listening to official
ben shapiro podcast and everyone else at
the real Daily wire my husband surprised
me with a two year subscription just
awesome glad you've been enjoying our
shows and now you get all the extras
that only a daily wire membership brings
thanks for the pic Casey an thanks to
your husband for his service in the US
Army also we have a beautiful picture of
a very very little child carrying a copy
of the US Constitution in one hand and a
leftist cheers tumblr in the other I
mean just gorgeous stuff this this is a
the young
daughter of Yael and Haim they also run
a great company called lavish layette
calm you can go check them out great
baby stuff I checked them out this is
what an adorable kid that is a cute cute
kid so we have a couple of winners today
in our in our left is tears tumblr
sweepstakes if that doesn't make you
happy and down dad no it does look at
that baby that's a cute cute baby and
check out their company lavish layout
while you're at if you need baby clothes
pretty awesome stuff also make sure to
check out our new Sunday special this
week I sat down with us recline the
opinion journalist podcaster and
co-founder of voxcom it's an animated
conversation it's really fascinating we
get into the details specifically of
identity politics he has a brand new
book out about why we're polarized I
have some quibbles but it is a
fascinating fascinating conversation
it's definitely not one you'll want to
miss it's great to have interesting
conversations with interesting people
with whom you disagree we had a great
one with Ezra that will be available on
Sunday so go check that out also as I
mentioned you should go subscribe over
at daily wire.com you should do that
right now one of the reasons you should
do that we're gonna start providing
additional services during this lockdown
or we're going to be that's what we're
seeking to do we're putting plans in
place right now so we can communicate
more with you we can hang out more with
you we're all gonna get through this
together so come on over to daily
wire.com and join the fun we will make
will put the we'll put the fun in
pandemic so go join us over at daily
wire.com we're the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
okay so we all basically know what we
need to do here that's not stopping
Congress from fighting over all this
basically because Democrats insist on
shoveling a bunch of crap into every
crisis bill you remember they did this
after Hurricane Maria remember that
they've been doing this for every crisis
every crisis is an excuse for the
government to spend endless amounts of
money well I'm not in favor of spending
useless amounts of money we should spend
the money we need to spend meaning right
now we have an unforeseen Black Swan
event that means there gonna be a lot of
people who are off from work there it
means there gonna be a lot of people we
want to encourage people who are sick to
stay home so the idea of a mandatory
paid sick leave is not a bad one we
don't want people spreading right this
is the pure externality situation you
have a disease you can't afford not to
go to work but if you stay home from
work you're not gonna get paid the idea
of the government stepping into the
breach there is not a bad one we have to
encourage people to stay home it makes
sense have a payroll tax holiday so that
companies have more money to spend on
their employees like listen we have a
lot of employees here you think that we
want to not pay our employees of course
we want to pay our employees I don't
know a single business owner who doesn't
want to continue paying their employees
I told you that my kids school got shut
down oh we have a nanny right because my
wife is indeed a doctor and that means
that the nanny has a child too and her
kids school is shut down we already told
her to like to spend whatever time you
need at home we're gonna continue paying
you right that is the ideal is that
everybody who is employing other people
wants to continue employing other people
whatever facilitates that is going to be
good especially because when we come out
the other end of this whenever that is
in june/july when we come out the other
end of this there will be a fairly solid
recovery and it should be fairly fast
because the fact is that this is not an
underlying threat to the global economic
system it's a threat to supply lines
it's gonna require some replacement of
factories but it's not because the
United States has serious underlying
economic problems it's because when
nobody is allowed to go out it turns out
the spending goes way down investing
goes way down why would you invest in
businesses also tip for people who are
in the stock market unless you have to
liquidate like right now because you
just don't have the cash flow leave your
money in the stock market
do not sell into a falling market you
want you want to talk about wealth
redistribution if you're a person who is
middle class middle upper-class and you
don't have to access that 401 K but you
think that the markets gonna drop
further so you don't say drop it right
now don't do it
all you're doing is giving opportunities
for younger people who have disposable
income the opportunity to go out and buy
all of that stock and then get rich on
the other end hey down markets are where
rich people get really rich
is the reality of the situation don't be
a sucker in other words leave your money
in the market do not pull your money out
of the market again I'm not telling you
which socks to bikes I'm not qualified
to do that
I'm just telling you why would you
possibly sell a depreciating asset when
you know it's going to appreciate again
in fairly short order meanwhile again
Congress continues to argue over what to
do about all of this
the legislation that Pelosi is proposing
includes enhanced unemployment benefits
which again depending on I mean we're
going to need cash transfers to people
who don't have a job right now
free virus testing aid for food
assistance programs and federal funds
for Medicaid okay so all this sounds
fairly good on the surface the question
the devil is always in the details
apparently Nancy Pelosi was attempting
to put in funding that was not subject
to the Hyde Amendment so the funding
could eventually be used for abortion
she's also attempting to make all these
programs permanent which is not the goal
here it's emergency funding measure it
is not a measure that is designed for
permanent places in American life no
this is not a situation in which we
should all be thinking never let a good
crisis go to waste that's not what we
should be thinking here the package
includes 14 days of paid sick leave as
well as tax credits to help small and
medium businesses fulfill that mandate
Pelosi says she wants another package
that will take further effective action
that protects the health economic
security and well-being of the American
people we will see exactly what this
stuff means because Congress is always
going to say that the question is how
much of that is legit and how much of
that is not really legit so once we see
more details on the bill then we can
tell you basically where where we stand
on what the government is doing and
whether it is a good idea for us to be
spending this sort of cash Peter
Sudirman has a piece over at reason.com
talking about these sort of stimulus
that all of these Congress people are
calling for he's very critical he says
the proposal as explained by the Trump
administration would eliminate the
collection of the individual employer
payroll taxes which fund Social Security
and Medicare the idea is to stimulate
the economy by giving workers bigger
paychecks they suggest that this plan
could result in a lot of lost revenue
that's true but it's likely to fail on a
lot of levels because not only would
have pushed the already high federal
budget deficit to unprecedented levels
it would also offer a little help to
those who need it most it wouldn't
address the underlying crisis or
anything like that also right now we
have a bit of a debt crunch because who
wants to buy debt in a time when again
the economy is sinking so we do have to
be
cific and careful about how we spend our
money we can't just start blowing wads
of cash and assume that the cash is
gonna be there on the other end okay
meanwhile speaking of politicization so
joe biden gave a speech yesterday now
imagine for one second just one single
solitary second that a Democrat were
president and let's assume that the
response were fairly similar because the
fact is their response would be fairly
similar okay Democrats don't have a
magic wand to suddenly make testing kits
available across the country any more
than president Trump does Falchi we'd
probably still be the head of the
National Institute of allergies and and
infectious diseases the same people who
are currently staffing would probably be
staffing the same problems that exist
would probably exist and all the
critiques would be coming from the right
now imagine that were a presidential
race and let's imagine was Barack Obama
and Mitt Romney again or something or
better let's imagine that it were
Hillary Clinton Donald Trump it was 2016
all over again and Barack Obama were
president and Donald Trump went on the
stump and then he gave a big speech
about how the administration was
completely botching the response to
coronavirus in the middle of what is
indeed a public a public panic right in
the middle of that went out there and
exacerbated all of the doubts that
people had about authority all the
doubts that people had about the
government all that outs that people had
about the measures that are being taken
place in the sufficiency thereof do you
think the media for a single solitary
second would sit there and echo the
complaints or do you think they would
say what are you doing it's a time for
us to come together it's a time for us
to all bring each other together and and
recognize I mean the election isn't
tomorrow the election is eight months
from now it's a time for all of us to
figure out what we can do best to bring
the country together right now instead
of sniping from the from the upper tier
but Joe Biden in his speech yesterday
widely praised by the media in which she
basically echoed most of the things that
Trump is already doing he just added a
bunch of snark so he suggested go out
and wash your hands yeah Trump has said
that before he suggested social
isolation yet we've we've talked about
this he suggested testing kits and
availability of testing kit do you think
the Trump isn't working on that of
course he's working on that but the
media were just over the moon about this
and this is why I say partisan politics
is a hell of a drug so here's Joe Biden
yesterday and again it basically his
entire speech was making snide remarks
about Trump's insufficiency in this
crisis people are gonna make their
decision based on the actions of the
Trump administration believe me Trump's
getting hit for having downplayed this
thing in the early days the Trump
administration has taken it on the chin
from people who think
that the the administration basically
wasted a month and not ramping up
development and testing but with that
said is it a good look for the opposite
political party at a time of what I mean
listen this is the this is the most
shocking public crisis that I have seen
in my entire life okay and I was alive
for 9/11 I was in your adult for I was
in 2001 I was 17 years old so I remember
9/11 fairly well the the public response
this Dwarfs 9/11 Dwarfs it okay my
parents have never seen anything like
this
my parents are 65 so like this is this
is a major moment when the country
really needs to come together and we all
need to rely on each other and we need
to we need to say listen there have been
failures in the past but we need to give
the government time to do what it needs
to do we all know what needs to be done
okay that the recriminations can happen
later believe me they will if you think
the Joe Biden is gonna kind of bevy of
ads in September of Donald's from
talking about how 15 people are sick and
it's gonna go down to zero or Donald
Trump talking about how he takes that
how this thing is gonna be fine in the
markets gonna be fine if you think Biden
isn't gonna cut those ads you're wrong
he's gonna cut those ads but now is not
the time for that bull crap right now is
the time when you say okay we need
whatever you think of President Trump
whenever you think of the administration
now is the time when we all have to be
together we're all working together to
get this right that's not what Joe Biden
did yesterday instead Biden decided it
was a perfect time to snipe so here was
Biden yesterday to the cheers of the
media being overly dismissive we're
spreading this information is only gonna
hurt us and further advantage the spread
of the disease but neither should we
panic or fall back on xenophobia
labeling kovat 19 a foreign virus does
not displace accountability for the
missed judgments that have been taken
thus far by the Trump administration
okay it is not xenophobia to point out
this is a foreign virus that is not
xenophobia it is a foreign virus and
again playing defense for the Chinese
government is a hell of a thing I mean
really the Chinese government is
responsible for the spread you don't to
call it the Communist Chinese virus
called the Communist virus fine do it
that way because the fact is that they
were literally threatening to imprison
people who talked openly about Wuhan
virus back in December and January so
all of the late-breaking
well you know now it's European yeah now
it's European so what Ebola didn't
stay in Africa but we still called Ebola
like the idea that is all about Trump's
xenophobia like really is this what we
need right now this is a public debate
we need right now not the encouragement
of everybody to take the proper measures
not the encouragement to to help out the
private companies that you know need
help and how about private people not
not any of that really when we're gonna
go on the xenophobia bender right now
we're gonna we're gonna go on the social
justice warrior bender in the middle of
the pandemic okay and it didn't stop
there Joe Biden again he was just using
this as an opportunity to to bash Trump
again based on nothing okay dr. Anthony
foul she knows a lot more about
epidemiology than Chobot he knows a lot
more than I do which is why I take his
word over Trump's I take his word over
Biden's I take his word over mine he
says that the European travel bans a
good idea here's Joe Biden saying it's a
bad idea it will not stop they need all
travel from Europe or any other part of
the world may slow it but as we've seen
it will not stop it in travel
restrictions based on favoritism in
politics rather than risk will be
counterproductive
hey Biden continued along these lines
and again it was just him ripping into
Trump I have question how does that help
you see that of a shadow government I
don't know about does he have any
capacity actually do anything the answer
of course is no as the head of the
Democratic Party right and he is he's
now the titular head of the Democratic
Party he's a Democratic nominee de facto
Joe Biden should be saying listen there
will be plenty of time for me to analyze
president Trump's response to this later
right now is the time for us to come
together here's the stuff that we should
be like that would be a graceful move
and Biden is supposed to be the graceful
candidate right it's Trump who is
violated all norms and of politics and
etiquette it's not Biden who's done that
supposedly but here's Biden violating
every rule of politics I mean this is
when you don't have to have a rally
around the Trump effect you don't
because whatever you think of Trump you
already think of Trump but you have to
have at least oh let's come together
effect you didn't get that from Joe
Biden last night when he was busy
yelling at the president here he was
talking about how the the president's
incapacity for dealing with this is the
reason he should be President Joe Ives
knew I've news for you the vote ain't
until November it's not until November
we're gonna be a lot of people who die
between now and November if this is your
chief message right now you're doing it
really this is it I think there's a
moral problem with this a real moral
problem with this because you're doing
nothing that acts
leads the Trump administration to better
better activity here protecting the
health and safety of American people is
the most important job of any president
unfortunately this virus laid bare the
severe shortcomings of the current
administration public fears are being
compounded but for base of lack of trust
in this president fuel by adversarial
relationships with the truth that he
continues to have our government's
ability to respond effectively has been
undermined by hollowing out our agencies
and disparagement of science and their
ability to drive of global response is
dramatically dramatically undercut by
the damage Trump has done to our
credibility and our relationships around
the world we have to get to work
immediately to dig ourselves out of this
hole and that's why today we're
releasing the plan to combat and
overcome the corona virus okay yeah but
you're not president you're not why are
you encouraging Nancy Pelosi to pass
legislation aren't you working with the
other Democrats to get something
together honestly the fact emedia we're
cheering this on demonstrates the Trump
derangement syndrome that has set in
there's plenty of fair criticism from
I've made a lot of it on this program
okay but it is not a correct thing in
the middle of a pandemic to spend your
time making giant speeches about how
everything Trump is doing is wrong and
he's bad for the job in all this I
promise you there will be plenty of time
for this campaign there'll be plenty of
time for this campaign and making hay in
the middle of an actual public crisis is
a bad look it's a very bad look okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
and then I wanted a little bit of Bible
talk so a couple of things that I hate
so if you remember I mean this is pretty
incredible
Andrew Gilliam was nearly governor of
Florida remember this Andrew Gilliam ran
is Democrat in in Florida he lost to Ron
DeSantis very very narrowly apparently
former Florida Governor toriel candidate
Andrew Gilliam was allegedly involved in
an incident involving crystal meth and a
Miami Beach hotel early this morning
according to an incident report obtained
by the Miami New Times the report itself
is super disturbing apparently an orgy
isn't suspected but unconfirmed if this
guy was like this far from being
governor of Florida he was the new
up-and-coming Democratic star
just a reminder politicians are people
too and most of them suck because most
people kind of suck
according to Miami Beach police report
clear plastic baggies containing
suspected crystal meth were found in
both the bed and floor of motel room as
3 small baggies buttons of suspected
narcotics were impounded at the Miami
Beach police station property and
evidence unit for destruction there are
photos of all of this furthermore here's
the crime report apparently two officers
responded in emergency mode to a cardiac
arrest upon arrival Miami Beach Fire
Rescue was on scene providing treatment
to one patient in Travis Dyson Miami
Beach Fire Rescue advised officers that
Dyson was being treated for a possible
drug overdose he was in stable condition
but he's being transported to a local
hospital officers then made contact with
two other males who were inside one was
a the complainant his name is Aldo
Mathias and Andrew Gilliam who wasn't
involved other according to Mejias he
provided his credit card information to
Travis Tyson to rent hotel room for the
night May house was to meet mr. Dyson
later on in the day Dyson rented the
room at approximately 4:00 o'clock
Mathias arrived to the hotel at
approximately 11 o'clock at night where
he discovered Travis Dyson and Andrew
Gilliam inside the room under the
influence of an unknown substance / mr.
Mejias mr. Dyson opened the hotel room
door and immediately walked over to the
bed and collapsed in a prone position
Mae house observed mr. Gilliam inside
the bathroom vomiting may he has stated
that he observed Dyson having difficulty
breathing prompting him to wake him up
Dyson then began vomiting on the bed and
immediately collapsed again officers
attempted to speak with Kellum Gilliam
was unable to communicate with officers
to hit to his inebriated state that guy
was this far from being governor of
Florida this far from being owner and he
was the new face and wave of the
Democratic Party Wow Wow
well that is just well done everybody
seriously well done okay other things
that I hate today so I've said before
that the that the late night industry
late night comedy industry is neither
comedy nor a political proof positive of
this Pete Buddha jej hosted Jimmy
Kimmel's show last night on ABC he's
like an opening monologue even hosted on
ABC - no audience because there's no
live audience because the coronavirus so
basically his campaign and basically his
campaign where he spoke to the plaudits
of people who are college-educated on
the coast and no one cared nobody
listened he wasn't very funny because
this isn't his job Wow look at that
audience a stunning audience look at the
social Wow look at the social distancing
that I got like ten people in the room
and Pete Buddha jej I mean thankfully he
didn't kill it like literally not Wow
the awkwardness the insane awkwardness
of of this of this monologue so we have
any audio of okay so Buddha judge he was
not great last night
the reviews were not particularly
sterling but the fact like can you
imagine if they just let Ted Cruz host
it host Jimmy Kimmel Live and of course
not of course not
so apparently the this was true across
across the evening by the way that the
audience's were not there boo to judge
because nobody's ever spoke like what's
amazing about the Democrats they've
never told the self-effacing joke so
Buddha judge joked when you don't have a
real audience you have to fake one just
like Trump's inauguration hahahahaha see
if Buddha judge actually made the joke
Here I am you know on a popular late
night show you know speaking to people
who are who are of my own ilk with no
audience that actually would've gotten a
laugh because self-effacing humor is
actually kind of funny but the fact that
people do judge was even doing this in
the first place
is really kind of amazing it's amazing
that this guy was hosting late-night and
demonstrative of where the entire
industry is okay you know what it's time
for a little bit of Bible so at the end
of the week it feels like biblical end
times but let's talk a little bit of
Bible so this week if I were going to
synagogue because synagogue is closed
then we would be reading the Bible
portion of Casilla of ki Tisa
as the the Bible portion in which there
is in which it talks about the the
golden calf and the Golden Calf incident
is really puzzling obviously because you
have a people who have just been brought
out with signs and wonders it
miraculously brought out of the land of
Egypt the sea is split for them they
walk across God talks directly to them
brings them the Ten Commandments and
then they're like you know we're gonna
do we're gonna make this fake cow let's
do that
let's make a fake cow out of gold and it
is indicative of the attention span of
human beings it is also indicative of a
lot of commentators suggest of the fact
that if you are going to have a true
long lasting belief in God it can't be
based on signs and miracles because
people tend to rationalize that stuff
away it has to be based on true faith
and a real rational perspective on
exactly run exactly how the world works
but there's something else here so the
real question is why Aaron who's Moses's
brother took part in all of this right
Aaron Aaron is one of the great figures
in Jewish history in biblical history
Maharana Cohen Aaron the Cohen he is he
is the secondary figure in in the entire
Pentateuch right I mean it's Moses and
then Aaron is the one who's actually a
spokesperson going on talking to the
people much more popular with the people
Aaron is more naturally gifted leader
than Moses Aaron is more powerful
speaker right Moses himself acknowledges
this when he's at the burning bush and
God says you should go speak to the Jews
and mostly I'm not sufficient for this
and then God says okay well you can use
Aaron right that is Moses acknowledging
that Aaron is actually a better leader
for the people in terms of the people
and in speaking directly to the people
but this is Aaron's downfall his Aaron
refuses to tell the people the truth
Aaron is more interested in public
approval at this point than he isn't
telling the people the truth and this is
obvious from the text of the Bible and
here's what the Bible says this in the
book of Exodus when the people saw that
Moses was late in coming down from the
mountain the people gathered against
Aaron and they said to him come on make
us guys that will go before us because
this man Moses who brought us up from
the land of Egypt we don't know what has
become of him Aaron said to them remove
the golden earrings that are on the ears
of your wives your sons your daughters
bring those earrings to me
and all the people stripped themselves
of the golden earrings that were on
their ears and brought them to Aaron he
took them from their hands he fashioned
it with an engraving tool and made it
into a molten calf upon which they said
these are your God's o Israel who have
brought you up from the land of Egypt
now the reason they did a calf is
because capsuled worshipped
in the land of Egypt and so they were
actually replicating what they had once
known is late when Aaron saw this he
built an altar in front of it and Aaron
proclaimed and said tomorrow shall be a
festival to the Lord so this is Aaron
trying to twist pagan idolatry into
service to God he's trying to take the
people and channel them towards
something better by exceeding to their
requests so how can our ins behavior be
excused so there are three basic answers
that are offered by the different
biblical commentators in Judaism first
they argue that Aaron was just trying to
stall that basically he assumed this is
gonna take a while to make this golden
calf
in the meantime Moses gonna come down
from the mountain will stop this whole
thing then there's the second theory
fear according to the Midrash which is
sort of commentary on the Bible that
fills out the narrative a little bit
Midrash says that the Jews actually went
to Aaron's nephew
they dynamic or before they went to
Aaron and then when court refused to
participate in their idolatry they
murdered him Aaron thought they'd
murdered him - at which point they
couldn't be forgiven their sins so he
thought that it was better to
participate with them in the sin of
idolatry than to involve himself in a
chain of circumstances that would lead
them to kill the high priest then
there's a third theory that Aaron was
attempting to take the sin on himself to
avoid the sin of the people but of
course that doesn't work because then
there's a massive plague that breaks out
immediately after this all three of the
theories have one thing in common
Aaron cares about the fate of the people
above all else the people are the
institution he seeks to preserve not
their honor not their decency not even
really their holiness their purpose for
existing this is Aaron's grave sin this
is very different from Moses right
here's how Moses responds to that
because God sees this right in the Bible
and God says to Moses I'm gonna destroy
these people I mean look at these people
these jerks look what all I do for them
I'm up here give me the law you're gonna
go down and bring them the most holy
thing I've ever seen the these Ten
Commandments and on these tablets and
they're down there making a golden calf
like what is this nonsense and here's
how Moses responds Moses pleads before
God and this is according the Bible he
says why O Lord should your anger be
kindled against her people whom you have
brought up from the land of Egypt with
great power and with a strong hand why
should the Egyptians say he brought them
out with evil intent to kill them in the
mountains and to annihilate them from
upon the face of the earth retreat from
the heat of your anger reconsider the
evil intended for your people remember
Abraham Isaac and Israel your servants
to whom you swore by your very self and
to whom you said I will multiply your
seed like the stars of heaven and all
this land which I said that I would give
to your seed that shall keep it as their
possession forever right what more is it
what Moses is is saying is he is he is
that God's honor is at stake but Moses
is chief concern here is that the Jewish
people cannot exist without their God
and when God threatens to remove his
presence from Israel and using angel
instead to take the people to Israel
Moses demurrers Aaron is concerned with
preserving life Moses knows that the
people have to come around to the right
answer right so so Moses never would
have acceded to the people's request
Moses would have said stick it Moses
would have told the people the truth
you can't substitute a fake God for a
real God and that God is not going to
live with your sin nor is he going to
excuse your sin and this has some
relevance to today's discussion and the
fact is here's what we deserve from our
leaders we deserve the truth it may be
unpopular it may get our leaders in
trouble our leaders may not win
reelection if they tell us the truth we
deserve the truth and not only do it and
it's not about us deserving the truth
it's about the truth being the purpose
of politics in human communication it's
about the truth being the only thing
that is going to allow us to retain our
morality and our decency in a grave and
serious time yeah we don't need leaders
who are simply going to tell people what
they want to hear we don't need leaders
who are playing politics we don't need
leaders who are acting on the will of
the people that's not what we need we
need people who are gonna speak ultimate
truth to people that's the story of the
Golden Calf Aaron should have said to
the people listen you do this and you
are violating every reason you're
brought out of Egypt you do this and you
sacrifice your souls you do this and you
betray the reason that God chose you in
the first place whether Moses comes down
from that mountain or not you are not
allowed to violate the chief precepts of
your reason for being okay telling the
people the truth is not put put aside
what the people deserve people deserve
whatever the people get but put that
aside what actually people need what
they need is truth so this time above
all else I urge everybody to engage in
the pursuit of truth and the speaking of
truth and that means speaking to people
about what they need to do at this time
it means not hiding the numbers it means
if it's scary it's scary but we can all
get through this together so long as we
base what we do on the truth okay a
little bit later on today we'll have two
additional hours of content otherwise
stay safe this weekend have a great
weekend with your family you'll really
spend some time well it can be fun right
and be home with your family I'm looking
forward to it so hopefully we will see
y'all here I might we will we'll see you
all here on Monday we'll recap
what's going on we'll hang out some more
otherwise we will you know otherwise
have a great weekend I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
I douse key technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 you know the
Matt Walsh show it's not just another
show about about politics I think there
are enough of those already out there we
talk about culture because culture
drives politics and it drives everything
else so my main focus is our life family
faith those are fundamental and that's
what this show is about I hope you'll
give it a listen